this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
oh the hummus gotcha huh
oh it was too much you're not supposed
to eat a spoonful of hummus that doesn't
make the medicine go down that [__]
spicy hummus tastes like a hindus
[__] toast
after he [__] runs two miles in
[__] india with the coveted vest
with the [__] cover there god knows
what else hummus when was the last time
you ate hummus before that
too long almost like a little bit every
once in a while but and the flies start
attacking you you see that you have no
flies around you anymore they were
trying to say there was a fly on your
neck
but i was like these [__] i
think it was i think it was it must have
been you there haven't been a fly since
i left l.a i mean it's the hummus like i
told you
when you need hummus it comes out of
your [__] pores as [__]
what what the what do flies like the
most [__]
oh do you ever see a piece of [__] take
a piece of [__] how long do the fly
lands on it [__] two seconds
and then he whistles for his [__]
friends and his family and they all
attack that piece of [__] till they get
down to the [__] granola bit i forgot
you used to like have flies as pets and
like do science experiments on flies now
flies don't even come around me because
you're not around see they knew i was
related to you
by [__] proxy even though you didn't
suck my dick and i didn't suck yours but
thank god they [__]
i can't even catch i don't even see a
[__] fly no more i was thinking about
that i found the can the other day my
little fly paradise
you took that home you took that from to
new jersey you brought that i worked
hard on that little [__] fly getaway
and [__]
that's my little fly getaway i had a
pond in there some thc deposits and [__]
i had a [__] room where they could
just hang themselves like a little rope
and [__] like just
it got too much the thc got too much
oh my god that's so crazy what are you
down now tarzan
144. jesus christ and what are you going
for
uh i want to get down to 150 so that's
another 40 pounds
and how much walking are you still doing
four times a week i do about
at least three miles no [__] how does it
take you right now 45 minutes to an hour
it's really not that bad like i do i do
it on the walk with my patreon we just
talk and it's uh
i actually like walking now i i'm never
going to be a hiker or like a huge
working working out person but a little
walk it it clears my mind
i it's it's fun that's why i like the
city more i like being able to like oh
i'm gonna go walk to the store now
in la you're walking and looking at dirt
and homeless people it's boring
it's funny because
you used to always say that the reason
why you put on so much weight in l.a was
beside the edibles the weed the hummus
the [__] uh you know the
the cheese covered fries and [__] was to
not walking
and i just came on a
couple months you know i went back to
jiu jitsu and i noticed that my cardio
was [__] again and you know you lift
weights
you do kettlebells you try to do
everything you can to i don't even know
what cardio is and then i started
reading
when i joined jiu jitsu and then i got
to covert i started reading those days i
had the covert
and ever since uh i don't know the last
week of december i've been walking on a
treadmill
and it's so weird how you find out a lot
about yourself because
i never looked at walking as anything
big i did it for [__] years in new
york walked from
port authority to 150 that's 40 [__]
blocks you know right that's a long
[__] that's a long and i used to do
that all the time i was a big time
walker
but i realized when i started walking
again and leave do you have a whoop
watch
i i don't i don't you gotta get a
[__] watch okay whatever it is a
month 30 bucks a month whatever
i got to tell you man i'm learning more
about myself every [__] day and every
day it's a challenge like you have to
beat the record from yesterday
and that's the one that attracts your
workout your sleep attracts everything
that's your workout your sleep with your
sleep is important it you know it works
on your [__] vitals your oxygen your
heart rate
you know for me being a [__] old goat
i like it and it works i never thought
that when i got it it was a friend
referred it
to me at jiu jitsu and i got to tell you
man you learn a lot
like i think i'm working out hard but
you ain't doing it yet
like
and then you go home put the watch on
and you're like [__] 4.4
what the [__] and they'll tell you you
went to lift but you did more cardio
based stuff so
get back to lifting you know and it just
really i like to sleep on it like now
i'm learning to [__] go to bed early
i keep my cuz i'll tell you go to bed at
11 13
and wake up at 7 48. he'll tell you
right he'll tell you what you need what
your body needs water it's [__]
pretty intense but man
i almost got as much as i swear to godly
and this is why i called you yesterday i
said i got as many happy birthdays as i
got
did you see lee
my facebook had about 20 messages and 10
of them were
were really happy for lee you know and
now i heard you got a podcast with the
girlfriend it's funny
oh yeah we just did we did an episode
about going to philly to eat but now
yeah i i appreciate it man it's um you
you were always in a nice way on me
about working out eating right and
i'm i wish i wish i had an answer to
this but i feel i honestly feel like
every person just has to be there
because i just wasn't
i just wasn't ready i guess because it's
just i've been on it for
14 months
and
i'm not doing really anything
that's special i re honestly the walking
is the working out i do i threw my back
out doing kettlebells and i don't do
that anymore
and
i have
regular meals it's just
i got this is the lightest i've been
probably since high school
and i'm just i like it i'm down to a 36
now i'm i was i was over 50 inch waist
when i left la
i was at i stopped at a walmart in
arkansas or wherever the head of walmart
is and i had to buy the biggest jeans
they had and they barely fit
and now i'm down to a 36 and like even
st steve simone and jimmy schubert they
took me walking when when we were still
in l.a during cover we went walking a
couple times a week i had to sit down
on the street i hated it
just little changes man i mean look at
you i i just like i told you yesterday i
just watched the sopranos movie you were
so much bigger back then
you lost a ton of weight too i bet
you know it looks like i lost weight but
it's deceiving i'm putting on weight as
we [__] speak i've gained like 10
pounds since the coven is it muscle do
you think
i don't have a muscle in my [__] body
i'm an old [__] giza but
i don't know what it is you know i
i've been eating the edibles again and
some of them like the all the delta
eights have
that sugar on them and [__] sugar is my
[__] enemy i mean sure is everybody's
enemy between the inflammation and the
weight i could eat 22 [__] pork chops
and not gain as much weight as if i eat
one [__] donut i like that shirt
thank you brother that [__] says [__]
rodney
that's a good album
yeah that's a good [__] album you got
some good albums there on the wall
[__] wanted that are alive
the pride behind you i don't even want
to say it cause people get pissed
you got my [__] album back there
that's a nightmare i like it
oh i do too i don't want to remember
it was [__] horrible i bombed the
first show
i had to change the set around it was a
[__] i'm not good with specials george
i'm just not a good special comic
i check on the pressure i'm only good
when i'm live [__] that [__]
yeah i feel you what's up buddy
nothing much man we podcasted last night
chilled
you know it's weird not having my dog
around man
i'm sorry about your dog it's a [__]
night man but give it a breathe and then
go get another one and now i'm not gonna
get no more that's it you're done i'm
done
yeah my daughter wants me to get a dog
here i gotta wait for the cats to die
and then i'll get a [__] dog i got
the yard and everything but you got to
be careful with dogs here because they
got the ticks from the [__] deer and
[__]
next thing you know you're dizzy
and that's [__] it how's it work
how's california treating you
california's good man the strip club's
good but uh you know the comedy store
they want like a full background check
now
[__] they're checking the bar
code on everything now
so what's the barcode it's on the on the
on the [__] vaccination yeah it's on
the vaccine
that card looks bogus
yeah
but the codes are put in the computer
and your phone number and your email and
your birthday come up
okay
so
and you haven't gotten vaccinated yet
hell no but i got the card okay yeah
that's the way it is [__] it don't let a
lot of people know they'll give you a
[__] felony that's the last thing can
you imagine
going a [__] having a felony because
you use the [__] covet card
and they give you like three years
because they want to make an example and
[__]
and you're in jail we covered
oh [__] dog that [__] is running through
prison
oh it ain't that [__] was running
through the prisons that's why they
inoculated those [__] first but
you know what they were sharing if you
had kovid
you were supposed to give it to the
whole dorm so people people had cobra
were getting released early
damn
what a [__] scam
hey dawg i've seen videos where fools
are like hey i got covered drinking that
eventually eat off his ball get it get
it you get to go home
no [__] how many people did they release
in california
i think they released like 30 000
god damn
[Music]
that's a lot of criminals walking around
doug yeah but it was like you know drug
charges nothing major
you know
can you imagine george being locked up
with covert now
i would have [__] i don't know how
[__] up it is to be locked up now
i've stayed out of that [__] hole for
30 years i can't imagine we're going to
prison this night now no smoking
yeah [__] just it's not you know you
did it we did it already we got it out
of the [__] way
you know i'm happy i got it out of the
way it's never going to happen again
i can never get [__] locked up again
dog that was
that's [__] up when they take away
your freedom that is [__] up man
people have no idea how [__] up it is
when a man wakes you up and kicks your
bed
you gotta sit up for a count you
remember that [__] yeah sit down and
wait for a [__] to walk by all
quiet [__] that
eight counts of [__] day
they come in and move your sheet at
night to make sure it's you that you
haven't escaped because i was at a camp
yeah i ended up at a camp you know i
went through the [__]
diagon i was thinking about diagnostic
the other day dog i had to go for a
blood test
and i'm like dog i'm gonna faint in this
[__] thing they had us like in a
little pod
i'm gonna faint and they're gonna [__]
me in the ass these [__] i was
petrified
and dog usually i tell a lady when she's
taking out blood to be a little careful
because i faint i didn't say nothing
no way and i sat down it was one of
those [__] school chairs
the desk
i put my little [__] [__] arm out
and [__] i looked the other way i was
trying to make believe i was hard and
[__]
and i'm like yeah i'm gonna do this and
[__] she shot me george took blood
out and uncle joey didn't faint
i walked in that [__] thing with a
stroll to me and [__] like what [__]
say something
later on i went to my room i'm like i'm
straight i put my arm down like let me
see what happened i took a piece of
cotton off there was a piece of cotton
with a little dot of blood i fainted in
my [__] cell duck i went down like a
bad habit i woke up 20 minutes later
with a lump on my head and [__]
[__] walking around with ice
to [__] nightmare when you try to be
hard and you ain't thug it's a [__]
nightmare
my diagnostics was different
uh
we were at war with like the prison was
at war with each other so they made us
sit in these [__] cages like in like
because no one was allowed to wait in
the doctor's office because fools were
fighting right there
and we were just waiting in those
[__] cages man and it's bakersfield
[__] freezing at six in the morning
dog
you're just sitting there waiting and
[__]
honestly i was worried because i was
[__] a lot of chicks back then and
they're like yo dog you find out if you
got aids today like i was worried they
were like yo they do every test and i
was just like damn
yeah thinking of magic johnson and
everything at that time i was like damn
dawg i'm gonna own the dodgers eh
it's crazy how when i got locked up it
was 87.
[__]
88 88 is when i got locked up i'm coming
on the anniversary now august 15th of 88
and
when i got locked up
hiv
was huge
oh yeah so the prisons had to build an
hiv wing
every jail i was at was under
construction
but when i got to camp george west and
golden
they already had an age unit george you
had to see this [__] thing
stated
state-of-the-art appliances they didn't
want these [__] in the kitchen
or nothing
no no they didn't know they had their
own setup state-of-the-art the [__]
they had a tv in their big screen tv
already in 88 i remember going in there
and watching the dodgers so we would
hang out at the age unit
my headquarters was the age unit that's
why i took book
that's why i brought my food that's why
i did everything was the hiv unit they
only housed five people and they only
had three people in the rooms
oh wow so they were like nobody talks to
us because they treat us like [__]
with lepers
so when i got there the one black dude
was tremendous and he's like come on
over say hello whenever you want i went
over there one time i didn't leave
i didn't leave they're like dog you got
hiv i don't give a [__] i'd rather be in
here with you guys i would wake up and
shoot over there those guys had
everything thank you for being here
thank you for checking in let's open up
the week with [__] ice cream shop
has got the blunts in stock they went in
partnership with packwoods laughing gas
is now in a blunt and let me tell you
something i hope you love your eyes
because i had to actually hold an eye
while i was smoking this [__]
your eye is gonna fly the [__] out
i want to thank [__] uh
pipe freeze for sending us a bung
freezepipe.com for sending us a new pipe
and a
little [__] smoker for my man mike
klein there
so now he's at home doing i love when i
give mike weed like i don't even have to
[__] ask him if the weed is good i
just wait a night and look at his
artwork when i see that a picture of the
devil [__] a monkey i'm like that
weed is good you know what i'm saying
i'll watch some of the rogan posters and
[__] and i go this weed is [__] hold
me up dude he asked me he told me the
other day
they're kind of out there
yeah they're out there because i'm
giving them the weed of death
there's one day i woke up he wrote three
songs he composed the [__] album
overnight i woke up at eight in the
mornings like i wrote an album and
performed it last night what the [__]
mike that i'm like i gave him that weed
he gets like lee remember when lee used
to smoke he's come up with business
benches i got a new idea for floatable
donuts you know [__] like that there was
always something every time you gave
them good weed they go home and they
come back with a [__] uh a guitar you
know they come home with something they
come back with some i thought you needed
a guitar that's [__] tremendous
so yeah it's uh it's always great to
smoke some good reefer on the [__]
weekend dog it was a great i i posted a
picture the other day
since i have moved here people have been
telling me about this restaurant el nido
joe you got to go to all nato joey you
got to go to home
it's close to my house
when i go to the gym i have to drive by
that
and i see the they have like little uh
boots outside that you could sit with
your girlfriend
just to learn a booth if you want they
could they close the curtains for you i
love that [__]
when i first got into comedy i used to
do comedy at a place called the broker
great [__] restaurant i loved it
until till this day i'm very loyal to
them they won't let me back in the place
to do comedy but
you know some people have short memories
you know saying
no everybody says everybody says they're
a christian but they don't practice what
they preach you know what i'm saying
so they had four restaurants they had
like the broker in boulder
they had the broker and like aurora
every one of them had a different name
but they had the broker in denver and it
was called the women's bank
and you're like the women's bank ah
until you went down there for starters
the broker when you sit down they'd open
up with a back with a [__] not a cup
not a not a thing not like a soup bowl
i wish i was exaggerating to you they'd
open up with a manhole cover filled with
shrimp
katrina shrimp you know the ones i'm
talking about the ones you dip in soy
sauce not soy sauce cocktail sauce if
you eat 20 of those you're going to [__]
blood because they don't clean them
they're just the little geeky ones but
you know what when you're 31 and broke
you will eat those [__] like
that filet mignon you know as you throw
them up in the air like [__] just
lick them out of the air i would go to
the broker just for the [__] shrimp
and they would bring you a bowl but the
thing about the ladies bank was the
woman's bank i'd take a date with me
come on dog when you're young and you're
doing a couple [__] bumparoos you
close the curtains you eat a monkey
and then breakfast is served you know
what i'm saying
boom the waiter comes my aunt might come
in absolutely you pull up a little
pantyhose
and you sit there and eat your [__]
shrimp you eat 20 shrimp you got a heart
on and you close the curtain again and
give another stab and doggy style nobody
knows nothing who gives about the flower
in her [__] it's a little [__] up you
smooshed it you know what i'm saying you
smooshed it [__] it but i like that [__]
when you could close the curtain and
stuff not that i would do anything
perverted down there but i'm saying that
so it seemed interesting to me you know
i'm like to have curtains then i joined
the pool and at the pool
there were these little [__] old
dudes
that were retired but there was this one
dude a jewish dude
sweetheart phil
he would always talk to me about
restaurants this guy would spit out
restaurants from boston iowa
because he traveled for a living so he
that was his thing
was hunting down restaurants
you know this guy could tell you like i
asked him about a restaurant he's like
what'd you think about the fountain when
somebody tells you
what you think about the fountain
they looked at all the details like they
like that [__] you know there's people
who live for that [__] and he was
telling me that that restaurant
is in the top five restaurants in jersey
he goes i did the math he goes this is
what i do this guy's retired he goes out
to dinner five nights a [__] week all
over the place plus my man dave baton db
orthopedics i'm gonna give him a shout
out he helped me with my knee he's
trying to help me with my right and left
knee now to get the arthritis out of
there
db orthopedics that [__] knows
every slice of pizza
every meatball from here to [__]
delaware it's unbelievable and he was
telling me like since the beginning even
when we go out to different dinners here
we go dog i'm going to take you to el
nido one day i'm going to take your
telnet but then i heard mixed reviews
people were like
it's really good but it's not my type of
italian food
and i get it and then people are saying
well they don't give you big servings
and i get it it's fine dining what are
you a [__] gorilla go to burger king
if you want to eat all you want to eat
yeah yeah you gotta have some [__]
cadence in your [__] life what are
you [__]
so i finally me and my wife you know we
try to do a date night once a month i
mean with the kid we we're out all the
time eating with the kids and [__] you
know medium range restaurants
wings pizzas i get the salads
[__] like that but you know you got to
take them to a carpet joint from time to
time you know what i'm saying you got to
take them through a rug joint you know
fine dining [__] some guy playing a
violin not that they're playing a violin
el nido they don't need to play a violin
they don't need no [__] gimmicks or
nothing
so [__] thursday night me and my wife
went down there
holy [__] that's all i could say holy
[__] first off it's all organic the
owner
his name is joe he's a 78 year old joe
rogan
it's like if joe rogan was 78 years old
when they bring you every dish they
explain the history
to you of that dish and what region of
italy it came from now you guys know me
a long time you ever see those waiters
they bring you a glass of wine and you
have to taste it then they stand there
it's like
yeah just pour the [__] glass well
you know i'm one of those [__]
gorillas too you know what i'm saying
but
uh
it was just sharp like from the minute
you walk in there we sat down [__]
you would never hear this word out of me
the ambiance is tremendous when he came
over he confirmed it you know i have a
problem hearing that's why i have those
hearing aids
i have a problem when i go to a
restaurant when two people when i'm
talking to mike let's say at a
restaurant i don't really hear mike i
hear the dishwasher in the back slamming
i can hear the cooks talking because my
hearing is [__] off so when i go to a
restaurant nine out of 10 times
the food better be good because if not
it's an uncomfortable situation for me
i'm unfunked and comfortable with that
like i i can't hear so when you're
talking to me not this place and when
joe the owner came home we were talking
he explained to me that he installed
something in the ceiling
so all the sound gets just
way ahead of the [__] curve
way ahead of the curve all their
ingredients 85
imported
i mean you got to taste this [__] he
grows all his vegetables
so when you put a vegetable like
whatever you think a green bean tastes
like when you taste it in there it's
what it should taste like the [__]
chicken in there
it it just breaks off it's it's those
chickens that have not been kicked so
it's like think about the [__] you can
discover and how you can grow we don't
get that it's like playing baseball
right like you [__] play baseball you
can work you can hit off a t you know
what i mean if you don't have anybody
else what you can throw a ball against a
[__] tree right you can like stretch
you can work out but in order to play
the game you got to have a bunch of
other people with all the equipment with
the field with the ball they got to be
willing to play they all going to be
allowed to be there at the same time
that's how you get better at baseball
you go to practice the way you get
better as an actor is you go to play
rehearsal you don't do it by sitting
alone in your [__] living room saying
the lines to a mirror you know you don't
say it by like the 10 seconds you get
between action and cut on a film set you
know you're driving in the car you're
saying the lines over and over what
[__] practice is that you know what i
mean rehearsal is [__] where you i
love it i love all that [__] i like when
they block on a movie yeah yeah i love
all that i've always loved i've been
doing that for eight hours dawg i gotta
tell you a funny story i don't know yeah
i told you so
we do the table read yeah ray's there
yeah
i respect the [__] out of ray leona you
know i love rayleigh
i say how you doing i keep it to a
minimum he's from union new jersey up
the corner here
so i keep it to a minimum i don't see
ray for like two weeks and we're
shooting and all of a sudden ray shows
up yeah you know and
it's like five in the morning
i'm in my trail of smoking dope and i
finished my joint like you know i go to
makeup and there's ray next to me i
don't say good morning how you doing
ladies good and also not on the way out
i go ray
not for nothing if you want to rehearse
the lines let me know yeah do you know
this [__] didn't even answer me
[Music]
oh yeah he heard me loud and clear and
he just looked over at me
and he just [__] turned his face i'm
like
[__] [__]
now we're getting to the scene yeah it's
a table and saturialis [__]
and he's sitting there at the end and
i'm sitting right next to him so i got a
liberal i don't say a word
so first line comes up hop along
quesadilla yeah what are you talking
about and then he starts with his frank
sinatra dean martin joke
and he's [__] it up yeah like he can
yeah we could talk about this i remember
yeah this was like first day he was in
there he's spitting food
he's trying to chew he's fighting food
with the thing in it dave [__]
what's his name leaves
uh
god bless him you know
whatever's david chase he [__]
couldn't take it
[Music]
because the [__] girl came over 20
times ray can you imagine coming over to
him
you know dog she came over 20 times ray
the line is gone and he's like wiping
his face and [__] like
you're like hey ray you want to rehearse
those lines
so all of a sudden again
action right it [__] up the line i
can't take it no more yeah yeah right
maybe you should have [__] read those
lines of me he just looked at me like
you he didn't like me that yeah yeah he
didn't even talk to me after that yeah
ray you should have [__] reversed
those lines you know yeah he got so
angry he just left
did you hear about that he just left we
shot that scene without him i i heard
him look like somebody there shot that
scene without him so he's ray liotta
he's the star of the [__] movie yeah
what are you going to do you know he's
having a bad day i don't say nothing i'm
dying to laugh
i'm dying to laugh he's spitting food
john he's going crazy the guy that's
playing silvio he's like what the [__]
is going on over there this is going on
for three [__] hours four hours yeah
finally ray leaves
he just left nobody said nothing i think
honestly people were like thank god
thank god
together read those lines off camera
i did not want to laugh yeah it's my
first
time with these people i don't want to
laugh and i don't want to be an [__]
so i'm not saying nothing about it i'm
just sitting there and from time to time
giggling by myself and then at one point
we're sitting there it's got to be three
in the [__] morning yeah we're there
from six in the morning and [__] yeah
john mcgowan looks at us there's like
six of us and he goes
what the [__] was going on with ray doug
we [__] lost it because everybody was
waiting for somebody to say what the
[__] was yeah everybody lost it yeah and
then we you know we pack up rap we all
get in the van we're shooting back to
the city we're sitting there we're tired
and out of nowhere the makeup lady goes
can i ask you guys a question
what was going on with ray leonard today
and this time the [__] driver of the
car the teamster was like he didn't he
busted out because he's like dog i was
listening to it
what the [__] was going on in there you
know he was just having but then
like i didn't see red
i didn't see him at all maybe one other
day and then i went to see the movie and
you see him in prison you're like oh
[__] he's a [__] killer he's a
[__] kid he's a killer that's dirty
[__] he's acting that's right what
i'm trying to tell you guys is
everything is great we got a great
interview today uh
you know
i've been podcasting for 10 close to 11
years now
i don't consider myself anything i'm
just a podcaster who's lucky
you know the joint does what it does i
don't sweat it
i'm trying to give a message out some
people i help some people i don't some
people like it some people don't it
doesn't make a difference to me
whatsoever some people moved on god
bless you
i'm happy that you moved on whenever you
want to come back you're more than
welcome here
but one guy that never moved on one guy
that i
is a [__] animal
is a kid by the name of cassius morris i
met him
10 years ago when he reached out and i
did his podcast and
i felt so good about
afterward because
i was actually
actually helping a kid out
with his dream this was i could tell by
talking to him
that this is what he wanted to do and i
gave him props you know when i was 12 i
didn't know what the [__] i wanted to do
i had no he
pinpointed it and stuck with it and now
he's 22.
he's been doing a podcast for 10 [__]
years you know he's a [__] great
media guy
and like i told him when you watch in 10
years he's gonna be the [__] king and
you you get to see him now
and uncle joey's joint enjoy it
joe diaz what's going on why are you my
little friend been a long [__] time
it has been a long time my man it feels
like we were in different worlds the
last time we talked i think right at the
beginning of the pandemic
was that long
it was that long man but it's okay i've
been i've been watching you obviously
everybody else has loving it man you
know i've been watching you too man you
had some sensational guests on there
thank you uh you're doing your thing
you're growing which is what i saw how
old were you when i met you
i was scratching my head there and i
going how old was i when i went on your
podcast first
right and i said a bunch of [__]
stupid [__] and
i left and i'm like how can i talk like
that in front of a 12 year old kid
what the [__] is wrong with me like
i felt like such a [__] douchebag but
then
you became my nephew and i forgave
myself how old were you the first time
we podcasted i had to be like turning
13.
wow you know and i mean i really
appreciated it joey because you were the
first person to really give me an actual
chance like that that was the the
opening to a lot of things for me you
know and that was a big chapter in my
life when i look back and think on that
it's uh
i can't even really describe how it
feels you know that somebody gave me a
chance like that that never went over my
head just so you know you know how many
[__] chances people gave me so
when i see a guy online
that's on there every day busting his
ass
i reach out you know we we would stop we
started talking we started complimenting
each other you know
i like that you were a young kid and you
were going after it you knew what you
wanted i think after the first interview
you were talking to me about not
going to school and yeah yeah l.a stop
and you know just
[__] that was uh i was really blown away
like how much
when i was 12 i thought i was going to
be a [__] basketball player but i
really didn't you know what i'm saying
like
i want to be a basketball player and
astronaut you know
the
idea but to really tell somebody when
you're 12 years old that you want to be
in media and
you know grow and interview bands and
you know there was two guys that
you guys really blew me away one was you
and one is the kid from rocking pins
okay yes yes i've watched
both of yous
right
take off while everybody else was
[__] crying
there's a
everybody else is [__] crying nobody
gives me nothing
you and mauricio kept pounding it out
pounding i still remember mauricio
paying for concerts
to take pictures and bringing them to me
at the store
and and telling me like how he had to
sneak in and they threw him out and the
whole thing and then he got a press pass
and he started going to shows now and
then he started writing a blog to
accompany the shows and
you know this is what it is
nobody's going to give you dick
everybody thinks they're going to give
you dick nobody's going to give you a
dick go get the [__] you know the other
day some guy hit me up and he's like i
want you to do this this this this the
podcast i go don't you do me a favor
start your own podcast
he didn't even have a podcast and he's
emailing you no and he's emailing me
like barking me orders and i'm like bro
you have the knowledge on this great guy
don't get me wrong he was a great guy
and you know why i told him to start his
own podcast
because he's got a great story
he's a cancer survivor which oh wow i
know if i had cancer
and i was at home sweating i mean i have
a dear friend right now that's going
through hell
and i i want to talk to a cancer
survivor i want to see a guy that made
it through the other side the same way
a guy that went to prison for four years
for a stupid thing looks at me and goes
wait a second that [__]
came out and did something different
with his life turned his life through it
i could do it so i told him i go you're
a cancer survivor
you could spread love you could save so
many people and give so many people hope
just by [__] one podcast two podcasts
tell them what you went through the
puking the chemo you know yeah
so it's just uh
it's a great thing that we're doing it's
great that we're still here [__]
pushing doing it it's nice that some
people stick around like obviously you
were always going to stick around joey
but it's like it's true it's like a
rotating door where it's there's not
many familiar faces that you can say
okay five six years ago they were doing
a show and stuff it's like it's
constantly changing you know so i
understand what you mean well this
pandemic made people stay home and yeah
i estimate uh you know 10 000 new
podcasts started right especially now
but as usual
as per
life is
people want to make money
and
they don't have the patience if you want
to make money go to the supermarket
stock shelves at night
yeah and then do podcasts in the daytime
and build it up
until it's like comedy it's like uh
being a guitar player it's like anything
else you know go get a [__] job
keep playing your [__] guitar right
but i work eight to six well you know
you gotta go to on stage from seven to
ten
and
some guy will say hey man
uh i do a band and next thing you know
you're making 200 a month
next time you know you're making 400 a
month
next thing you know you're making 750 a
month you know and now you're like [__]
it
now i know what i got to do if i can
make 1100 a month okay that means i got
to get rid of my cable
i got to get for me to live my dream
these are the things i got to sacrifice
there's so many sacrifices
you know it's incredible i don't even
have a tv in here joey like in my new
spot because i was looking at tvs and i
said
why would i pay
hundreds of dollars that i'm never gonna
get back to waste time
i was like let's get real here because
i'm looking around and i'm like time is
not some like
it feels like just the other day you and
me first met so it's like time is not
something that is that expendable you
know what i mean so it's
it's uh it's it's insane and i feel like
a lot of people they want to talk about
what they want to do they want to watch
videos of bill gates and sit and
fantasize but they don't want to
make moves to make that transition
because if you say something they're
going to bring you in it's like i was
watching the sopranos that guy that was
a witness and he told the cops i'm a
good citizen i should have said
something then two weeks later his name
is in the paper and he's like i'm gonna
get killed by the gangsters that's why i
shut your [__] find your business set
your [__] box sometime you want to be
a [__] playboy or a boy scout do it
on your own [__] time go tie a
shoelace
go bring a donut to a homeless guy what
the [__] is wrong with you but they're
doing great and i'm you know what i'm
happy for him a lot of people turn that
back on him he got to see
where he stood in life yeah and once you
see where you stand in life
you're [__] brand new you're brand
new he's got nothing to talk about
nobody to talk with [__] you you said
[__] about me on twitter yeah and he
moves on i check him with delete all the
time
i love
his parents are awesome like i love that
come on man
what happened was he was [__] people
when he was being a dick
you're not going to chick sucks your
dick you're like oh you're finished get
the [__] out of here you can't do that
for these chicks these chicks actually
think that they want to get married to
you or something
so it was just a bad situation i'm happy
we all moved down from that
i'm happy all the stupid [__]
that people were saying [__]
everybody moved on from it and now you
see
now you see why we're the way we are now
now what do you got now you got
comedians that aren't going to [__]
talk to you yeah that's what you got now
talk to they're scared i know a comic no
names he said he will never do another
meet and greet he doesn't give a
frenchman's [__] yeah because god forbid
you touch somebody wrong whatever so
that that's what you get now that's what
you get you want to complain about
comedians you know that's why dog and
there was
still some creepy [__] i got
i took a picture with a [__] i told
you about that three years ago i went to
like toledo
i went to toledo ohio was that would you
tell them
okay yeah the funny bone yeah yep
years ago five [__] years ago
in between a dog it was so long i don't
[__] remember
i took a picture with a [__]
i was in the hot lobby in the hotel
like about five or no no on a saturday
especially in a small town because
everybody knows you're at that hotel
yeah i went out for dinner but it was a
smaller hotel didn't have room service
usually for dinner at any hotel on
saturday
i just have room service because you
don't really want to go out i do all my
[__] early i go to the gym and then i go
up to the room about four watch tv for a
little while
and then i didn't do that that day i
went out when i came back they were
checking in now she was really
attractive so was he they were a young
couple they were like 32 yeah she took a
picture of me
he took a picture of me then they both
took a picture of me
never thought about it again
hi goodbye they said i was very
approachable whatever two years later
i'm getting a [__] email
looking for my address
he was filing for divorce and he used
one of my pictures with the chick to say
she was cheating on him huh that's
terrible i'm saying so now i got an
answer to an attorney and all of you
know they hit up an attorney yeah the
attorney might hit me up
well you have
oh my god
so with all that [__] now how do you
feel after that do you want to
you know how do you want my behavior to
be after that
you know ufc fighters are taking
pictures with people they would say get
me in a headlock and a year later
they're getting sued because they said
when you got them in a headlock you hurt
their [__] neck
and it sucks because like the vast
majority like
95 percent of people we meet or i've met
through this have been so cool
but the crazy have gotten crazier
and it's just
it's not it like it's just not worth it
like as much as it would suck to be like
i can't take a picture but it's like is
this the one time i take a picture and
someone says i did something or even
yesterday some guys first time in six
months anyone said anything to me about
the church
some guys stopped me at a gas station
but they literally pulled over they
weren't even really in the spot they
left the car running and i was like am i
about to get [__] like
like
something yeah
like i'm nowhere in the middle of
nowhere in connecticut but it's all like
you think about it now i get it and mine
is
a hundredth a thousandth of what you're
like
i said last night as a joke to like how
often do you get recognized because it
happened last night when we were out and
your wife was like oh every day
like that
that's a little bit much
that that must get a little bit old no
you say hello to people there's some
people who are last night i was in the
rest no friday i went to a restaurant in
cold snack
and
i thought i got 12 kids
and i got 12 adults
you know i got like six sets of parents
and we're sitting we just come from a
tag a flag football game
and we're sitting there we're having a
good time with the kids and all of a
sudden a guy comes in with kids
and they stop because the waitress is
there and i make eye contact with the
guy
and he looks at me like what's happening
he goes how are you doing man he goes i
love you in the longest shot he shook my
hand and he kept moving with his great
people yeah that's it
he goes that's mercy i go yeah i listen
to the podcast he walked away yep
there's some other kid i was going to
say good people make it easy to be nice
but people make it easy they make it
easy they make life easy but then
there's problem people where is going
and i got two kids around me i got the
my daughter's sitting on me and i got
the neighbor girl busting my balls
because my pants were short and they
could see my ass cracked so the neighbor
girl kept saying i'm gonna throw pennies
in there mr diaz
and listen some kid goes are you joe
diaz and i'm like
no you got the wrong guy just because i
knew
what he wanted when you see a guy with
two kids he was he was excited you know
he was very excited he was young and i
knew he was going to hang there he might
even slip and say where's the reefer at
or something yeah i'm sitting next to a
cop
detective
you know he knows i get high but i don't
want to slam it in his face right so i
go nah nah and he goes everybody [__] it
you look just like him anybody ever tell
you that and the detective goes i tell
them all the time but he looks just like
joe diaz he won't listen and everybody's
laughing at the table and the guy's like
man you look just like joey i didn't do
that because i was a scumbag i did it
because i know that
what i was just going to open the other
guy had kids with them and yeah
nice you know whatever polite i love
talking to people i love listen i'm a
chatty you know what i'm saying like i
love talking to people so if you're cool
with me
and you approach me the right way i'll
talk to you
for 10 [__] years the other day i
went to loboties ended up talking to
some guy out there for [__] 20
minutes about
uh cgi yep you know he just he came up
to me he's like i i'm in high school and
i want to learn he goes when they shot
you in the sopranos did they really and
we talked yeah he didn't want to take a
picture he didn't give a [__] about
comedy
polite polite and respectful respect
that like i remember being in a bar i
wasn't even drinking but i was like five
years ago or whatever bartender slammed
and uh you know i catch the oil and i
said excuse me i could say that you're
busy but when you have a chance may
please get a diet coke with no ice
guy goes what he said i understand your
pc
but when you please just a diet coke
anyone you know what whatever you want
it's free i go what he goes
order whatever you want he goes you're
the only polite person we've had in here
in a year use whatever you want i got it
like because people don't do that
anymore there's no more common courtesy
i think that over the
with the situation the last two years i
think
you know man i i call it like a mental
health issue because maybe i had a
little bit of a mental health issue
but at times when you see all these
planes and stuff i i was thinking about
the planes that it was
people have been in the house too long
and they found out how to act well she's
thanked me
about a week two weeks ago my daughter
took me aside eight years old and she's
like dad thank you
for bringing me here thank you for
turning me on to your food she [__]
loves white castle
you know she'll ask me twice a week can
we go to white castle you know yeah she
loves [__] carvel i mean i took her
out
yes she loves carvel she's all over
[__] carvel
uh well yeah last night she asked me
because i took it to a football game
she's like you know it's uh get a sunday
free today carpel
i'm like when i [__] go in the car
about because i i take it once a week
for her yeah every now and then her a
little [__] uh vanilla ice cream soda
yeah but even like i could tell how she
treats
the people i grew up with
right contrast to other people she
really digs them
she really goes out of their way to talk
to him she's at she asked some questions
like did you go to school with my daddy
you know
so she's really appreciate that's what
made me happy
right right now i got to be honest with
you i've been having an alright time
here
but watching her have a great time
makes my dick hard
what's the difference between when you
grew up there and now how what what are
the major changes holy [__] it's listen
i grew up in a city that was book
[__] wild no rules i was getting
dressed yesterday in the shower and i
was thinking about
a friend of mine getting me a job one
day and before he left the room he goes
enjoy your job you know and he goes
don't forget to steal because if you
don't steal
they're gonna know i was stealing who
the [__] tells you that in a society
so it was buck wild up there i live an
hour from where i grew up
where i grew up is really [__]
populated it's right across the hudson
river from new york city
so
i didn't want to move up there there was
no way i was moving up there right i'm
in a place now
where
you know it's wide open there's trees
the other night i was smoking a joint on
my front porch
and two deer run ran in front of me i
thought i was going to have a [__]
heart attack them dylan
i thought i was gonna [__] my [__]
pants when i seen those uh deer and my
front porch at a quarter to eleven i got
a cup of tea in me and i got half a
joint i'm just sitting and i heard this
[__] thing
and the two deer jumped out in front of
me and i almost [__] my it's a different
world tim yeah it's a different world
you know and uh
i'm happy i got to bring her here i'm
happy my wife is here she's having a
great time my wife had friends my wife
has friends now that don't give a [__]
who i am
right you know before she would make a
friend and after two weeks the girl
would say you know can we bring give
your husband a script
and my wife would go is this what it's
all about and then when my wife tells
him no
they stopped talking to my wife that was
la for my wife yeah let's see what they
could get out of her on her end
and uh if nothing move the [__] on you
know so
she's in a different place now she's
surrounded with real parents
yeah they care about their kids yeah
these people are not you know in l.a
people use their kids they're pimping
out their kids it's a [__] marketing
[__] tool
yeah no it's crazy
dope i know people who have a kid just
to put them in carpenter yeah they don't
give a [__] about the kid carpenter
school for people don't know it's in
studio city right and it's a grammar
school but it's where all the [__]
celebrities go their kids go to school
yeah and they have their christmas party
at cbs radford on the lot
yeah [__] public because i have a
godson who's like a quarter filipino but
we say chinese because we want them to
you know higher end we say japanese or
chinese we don't admit to filipino but
he said but he's the chubby
baby with the asian face i go let's get
him in some let's make a couple of
dollars here you know because the
reality is is you know he the only thing
he could be is is a nurse really because
his mother's in our filipino nurse i
said so let's just make let's get him
like he'll drink some juice he eats the
doughnut
let's make a few hundred grand of this
[__] before because he might
grow up to be a beautiful kid but he
also might grow up to be absolutely uh
disgusting we don't know
so i get it like in la like sometimes
you just gotta make the money while
they're young
let me tell you something i remember
going to [__] auditions
for commercials and seeing like you know
when you go to those auditions they have
eight rooms right and they have one room
that's for kids like kids come and
i would sit there and just watch the
parents
and watch the kids and [__] get sick
to my stomach yeah how the parents were
like because the parents are like pistol
pete's father yeah they're pushing the
kid they're telling the kid he's got to
get this audition the [__] poor kid
wants to play with blocks right you know
some of those kids are psychopaths you
know i well i was an actor as a kid when
i was young i was on sesame street i
started in plays when i was like six no
[__] swear to god and i legitimately i
did i toured around the country with a
show my mother went on tour with me i
did a lot of theater i did a i did
sesame street i did a stu nyu student
film i never did anything big i tried
out for big [__] but i never got like
home improvement or any of those big
sitcoms i never got him um
and my parents were like they they
weren't good at being a stage mom like
they should have been pushier and more
aggressive but they weren't and then
every time i would fail at the audition
we would go home through penn station in
new york city and i would go can i go
can i go to dairy queen and they would
get me a dairy queen blizzard and i
would eat it like a failure in the
waiting room
of the long island railroad and i would
get i would get like i forget what kind
of get i get an oreo or reese's peanut
butter cup blizzard and i would just sit
there and eat it like a failure and then
we'd finally take the train home
so it was a tragic thing but i i had fun
doing it but i never made it
but in minute 13 i became a cocaine
addict so maybe it's not good you
started snorting at 13. at 13 yeah holy
[__] summer going into high school yeah
jesus christ tim dillon what haven't you
done i was at my friend tina deluca's
house and we're in long island and she
had a nice house on the water and she
goes we got you know me and a couple
other friends with aaron you know they
were like let's try cocaine i said that
sounds like a great idea and she had it
and we did it didn't even work
i didn't the first time i said uh it
doesn't even we had to keep doing it and
doing it and then finally
uh you know it took you got to drink
with it yeah yeah it took eventually but
i mean i was smoking wheat i was doing
acid
uh you know all of those things yeah
first type of acid i was in um
my
first tab of acid you're gonna laugh
was at my friend's house
i was in eighth grade
the second time i did acid i was on the
graduation stage
of my junior high school and me and my
friend shea and my friend tina were like
a three
uh we all took ataba acid and we were
standing there and the valedictorian is
up there wouldn't shut up some you know
some asian girl
and uh she was talking and talking god
bless her but she was talking about
you know whatever you know and we were
just standing there and then finally we
went to the beach afterwards and we were
all
we were finally tripping but yeah i
started really young and then i sobered
up at 25. so i had about a 10-year
period of of being out and doing wild
[__] now you sober today sober is a
church no drinking no smoking
no pills no weed nothing
how long now
about 11 years no [__] tim though 11
years yeah you what your skin's glowing
what kind of face routine you got going
on huh no no refill all [__] day
just to join at night i'm getting some
good sleep there you go i'm drinking a
lot of [__] water i love that and uh
vitamin d you know jersey vitamin d
mixed with a little pollution it's the
best a little cancer in the air it's
good for you i love that smell when you
land like when i get back from la and i
land in new york like the smell of like
new york pollution and trash like i love
it it makes me feel good it's in my
blood
there you go
it's uh it's quite i like when you're
driving on the turnpike
and you get that whiff that those
[__] odors of new jersey like
and you see that stack blowing the
[__]
smoke into the air and god knows what's
up there in the marsh you have like the
marsh and who knows how many bodies are
buried in there
i do know how many bodies are buried in
there there's a lot
in fact i saw a foot sticking out the
other day on the 18 i'm like i'm not
even going to bother that [__]
it's funny we were driving on the 18 the
other day my daughter goes dad i just
saw a bear
and my wife is like let's pull over i go
[__] pull over what is this a zoo
this ain't no [__] zoo we're not
pulling over nowhere yeah no way i love
that
i love that how you been
i've been good brother i've been good um
you know getting ready for the movie to
come out i've been doing all this sort
of press which is like so incredible and
so
weird and like talking about myself a
ton it's such an interesting [__]
experience it's like
i don't know i feel like you know like
i'm just a normal guy so it's so weird
to like um
you know have all just answering all
these questions about me and my life
it's it's been
tough and fun and hard and scary and
exciting and all that stuff
good how does it feel to be less than a
month away
from being in one of the best films of
the year
oh man um
i'm excited i'm just like excited i'm
really
i'm proud of what we did man i'm really
proud of it and uh you know that's the
feeling i have and like proud for
everyone to see it and
can't wait to get everyone together
it'll be like our family reunion you
know how are you feeling with it coming
out
i'm uh
this has been a great experience for me
from the beginning
all the way to now the shooting inspired
me to move back here yeah just coming
back for that movie inspired me in a way
to go what the [__] where have i been
what the [__] am i doing with my life
living out in la i'm ready for jersey my
daughter
needs it um the set was one of the best
sets i've ever worked on in my life
it was no drama you know another la
[__] on the set you could tell the
big difference between shooting in new
york and l.a yeah that's a big big
difference
everybody was dynamite we laughed our
asses off there were long days you know
but they didn't feel long like i've
worked on movies before where you're
like this sucks yeah this was coming
home at six feeling like
you just went came back from an orgy you
know you just
like i believe they're going holy [__]
that was great today you know
oh yeah david's directing and you know
what you learned from him and just
everybody everybody it was just a
phenomenal experience and uh
i saw the movie and when i went to see
the movie
i had expectations so i don't know what
the words i'm looking for are
and i was blown away
i was really blown the [__] away to the
point that i sat there for like five
minutes
going what the [__] did i just see yeah
and i think the biggest takeaway
i got from the movie was how good you
were
how good you came through
how great your arc was
your article you got to remember or
i only did one scene with you we never
saw each other you never saw each other
you were always off duty when i'd see
you that was [__]
or whatever so we were never together
except for that scene and that was john
scene so we had nothing to do in there
so i never really got to see you till i
went to the movie and i was like
on the drive home i was like that
[__] better be ready for what's
coming his way after this man i i really
i
i really really really appreciate that
you know especially coming from you and
it's a testament to you guys i leaned on
every
one of you and like you said like we
didn't have a lot of scenes together but
all of us who are a part of it like
david
david is
such an incredible artist not only in
his writing but like in his casting i
mean he created a family and i got to
lean on you guys and that's what i did i
just leaned on you guys and learned from
you guys and
um like you said like you know a lot of
people sometimes ask like
was it super intense was it hard and
like you say of course it was hard and
intense but it was a [__] blast like
it was so fun we left our asses off you
know i mean i we were doing 14 15 16
hour days but on days that i had off not
every day but on some a lot of days i
had off i'd come to set i just wanted to
watch like i wasn't gonna not watch you
guys and get to watch these incredible
actors and people work like i love just
being on set it was the best you know
it was the best i really uh
learned a lot from david
like i was a big fan of the show
but i like the humor of the show like i
have always said the uh
when they do the intervention with
christopher
that is some of the funniest [__]
things i have ever seen and i'm a pink
floyd i'm a pink floyd pink panther guy
i'm a pink panther guy i love the pink
panther and that's what that reminded me
of like oh when paulie goes to the
psychic and he throws the chair oh my
god
oh my god there's just so many
[__] scenes that are
hilarious that you really laugh
and i remember
it was my first day on the set
and we had to do a scene
and i was doing the comic thing i was
trying to improvise
and i remember somebody came over and
they went
don't do it just sit and learn
and i remember doing it
exactly how they wanted me to
yeah and all of a sudden i was in the
twilight zone i was in the soprano
episode yeah because david is the king
of silence yeah
he's the king of making silence like
when you're a stand-up comic
you come from a school michael that you
tell a joke and it should vibrate
and then it comes back to you but let
the joke sit
don't step on it and a lot of comics
including myself
you know you're on a roll so you just
keep hitting them with [__] left you
know with
hard right hands
it's great once in a while to hit
somebody with a right hand that was your
intro
to this life
that was my intro could i tell you
something about brutal honesty and this
is the god's honest truth who's ever
listening to this
when i was in the room with the casting
director
and i wish they still have that tape
i won't say everything i said right now
but i'll say some of what i said she
said when you're done with those sides
tell me who you are
and on god i looked in the camera
and i said my name is cat and i was
always brutally honest like you
and that is a loaded question tell me
who you are even on regular nine to five
job interviews
the worst question they could ask me
because that's how i didn't get the job
in that world
tell me who you are and i said my name
is catherine narducci
and my whole life i knew i was supposed
to be an actress and everywhere and
every job i ever had i would look out
the window and daydream that i was
supposed to be an actress and i wasn't
supposed to be there that i was supposed
to be right here
and my father was murdered when i was 10
shot down my mother suffered from mental
uh nervous breakdowns my whole childhood
i come from a very dysfunctional
childhood my sister my dad
i spilled out all my family dirty
laundry
and then i just went
oh my god could i do it over she went no
thank you
and i went i'm not gonna get the [__]
job i just blew the job i knew i did a
great audition but i just blew the
[__] job
and when i got that job
de niro said to me the first day of work
you know why you got this and i said why
it goes because you told the truth in
your
audition stay with that honesty stay
with that that's how you gotta act just
be really honest
that's what acting is
it's honesty that is one of the best
[__] stories i've heard
in the entertainment business and 23
[__] that is great
that is tremendous and you took the ball
and ran from there it's never stopped
well it's always been a struggle i mean
i'm a working class actress i mean i'm
no a-lister i'm a worker you know i work
a lot
sometimes i don't work
sometimes i work
but
no matter what
you know
i always say this people when they go
you know even when i taught i taught
like a couple semesters at um school
visual arts i say if you're not willing
to
just work the rest of your life
if i told you you would work the rest of
your life in a broken down theater
nobody will even see you but you can act
in that theater you can do all the plays
you can do [__] you can do that the rest
of your life you're an actor
but that's where you'll do it will you
still want to be an actor
and if they say yes then i say then do
it because you'll never be miserable
when you're not working you'll never be
miserable when you got told no you'll
never be miserable when you don't work
for long periods of time because you're
just [__] happy
being who you are and what you were
meant to be
so when i had dry spells
of course i wanted to work because i
needed to pay my bills
but i never said all this [__]
business oh [__] this [__] that i was
never not happy for my friends that
worked all the time all my friends
worked all the time
and
i was always still happy for them and i
was happy for them because i said
i want to be around working actors i
don't want to be around a bunch of
non-working actors although i was around
a lot of non-working actors i like being
around working actors it teaches me and
it gives me hope i want you to get it
even if i don't get it because then you
are my inspiration if she got it i can
get it
that's how i always took it when
somebody else got my job that's not my
job i got the job that's how i look at
things
because i just want to be an actor i
don't want to be famous i just want to
be an actor and i want to be able to pay
my bills and i am successful
you are
that's a great attitude to have
and you haven't stopped since i remember
after the sopranos ended i saw you at an
audition for something
to play a cop or something oh
i think it was csi new york
i think we auditioned i think so i think
it was yes
no i just said hello to you
you had on pants you were dressed like a
cop and that's the only i was i've been
thinking about it for the last couple
days
what auditions i went in that time and i
think it was csi new york
when it first came out
like the original cast like this wow to
shoot the pilot
so it was a long time ago but you have
not [__] stopped how did you end up
getting the sopranos
kathy moriarty called me
who i love
and to me she's such a [__] great
actress man yes she is um kathy moriarty
called me she goes nah dude she named me
not dude everybody calls me not douche
no don't you kitty and my two nicknames
she goes no douche you gotta go for this
show uh the sopranos and i was like but
i don't sing
she goes no it's not about that she goes
you got to go in you're right for it
call your agent i call my agent he goes
all right i'm on it and then i got an
audition i i auditioned for edie falco's
role
and they call me back
of course only edie could have done
edie's role brilliant edie who i love um
edie falco's role and then they call me
back and
i went in for charmaine bucco and uh i
got called the next day for that they
said you know david wants to give you
charmaine bucco so i was blessed
again
blessed
unbelievably blessed you did great on
that show you were great [__] great
thank you
and now we're here you know what i'm
saying i'm sorry you're not gonna go to
the premiere
i would love to see i heard from vinnie
last night
well no you know what wait let me tell
you we i think we're all i mean i'm
invited to the many saints of knowledge
yes yes um premiere but
i may have to go back to the show that
i'm blonde for
if i don't
i definitely want to comment and i and i
want to see everybody i would hope all
the soprano's gone i love i love steve
we all love seeing each other and i get
to see you
yes no they're all supposed to go i
heard from vinnie last night
and he said he'll see me at the premiere
i heard
from a friend of sheriff's he's going so
yeah everybody's going to be there oh
and i'm so happy
i i you understand i did the wizard of
lies with alessandra yes yes and i
me and alessandro i love him and i love
his wife and i love their family and
i just
am so happy for him i am so happy for
michael
i'm happy for david chase he's
unbelievable if you don't stop
i'm i'm just i'm just really happy about
this movie i'm happy for you
i'm just it's so everything's a win-win
yes it's a win-win i'm happy for dave
i'm really happy for michael
and i think i hate talking [__]
but i think alessandro is going to come
out with an award from this [__]
thing
or at least the nomination
yes when he got it
yes he's going to be
i think this is a good movie i think
they all did well you saw it yeah but i
think it's gonna be difficult
how did you like yourself
in all honesty
yeah i looked away
why i hate looking at myself on film
you want to know could i say something
you told me about the not me you told
the whole world three the three things
the three uh
the three things you you know are uh
appreciated
great grateful for i'm gonna tell you
something
when you watch yourself
watch it again
go with a different perspective
and
love yourself and say wow self
you doing pretty [__] good from a kid
from [__] nothing look at you up
there look at you look at your eyes look
at your mouth look at your nose your
ears your hair look at your body you're
up there you're in a beautiful movie
you're so blessed look at you kid look
at you kid look how good you're doing
now and look at yourself beautifully
because all that put together
made them hire you
and and and appreciate it let that be
one of the things i appreciate me on a
screen with all these fabulous people i
appreciate me
being able to be seen and heard i
appreciate me to be doing what i love i
appreciate it i appreciate
my face my body that's what got me there
i'm healthy i see i breathe i taste
i hear i i have you know all these
things all these things that put me
together me me me
i appreciate you i appreciate you joey i
appreciate you and let your little inner
child that was beaten up and broken down
look up at that screen and say
we did it
that's [__] beautiful
that is as
beautiful did it
we did it we [__] did it
and i don't care if it goes nowhere you
never work again you [__] did it
you [__] in a child
that tries to keep going the sparkle in
your eye the honesty you have
all the things that make you
did it
so look at it again differently
i'm like you captain right here it's all
about this right here
that's me and my mom
she died when i was 16
and this is it right here
she wanted me to grow up and be a man i
did
we did it
we [__] did it the nora i'm funny my
mother was bunny and she's up there too
and nikki my father but
i don't care scrappy kids from nothing
i don't care how big or small
we're trying give yourself a [__] hug
give yourself a break give yourself a
little pat on the shoulder
appreciate the little moments because
that's your life right there right now
this moment
it's every single step we take it's our
life that's it can't keep waiting for
the big event the big this the big
apartment my biggest my most happiest
times is when i [__] had nothing you
know as a kid i was homeless a couple of
times we slept in central park on
newspapers and
very you know short period of time like
two weeks then again we did it for a
week and i gotta tell you we got evicted
i was still so [__] happy
like what the [__] is am i stupid
like i just
feel you've got to appreciate your life
the good the bad the ugly it's your
[__] life and then it's over
then it's over
and right now
it's like you're here appreciate it and
you're not gonna be miss happy go lucky
or mr happy go lucky all day every day
and appreciate but
try try try
to to just appreciate it like you
looking at yourself on screen
look again man look again to that little
joey diaz
[__] 10 year old that was going
through a [__] look again and go man
what the [__]
you got up there we did it
we did it
that's it it's to be appreciated
i really appreciate it now now you
really gave me a different appreciation
for it
yes
i love you you made a mark in this world
you really [__] this is one of the
best podcasts i've done in a long
goddamn time
you scream oh don't make me cry you
[__] schooled me today i love it i am
uh blown away i had tears in my eyes
you made me think about my mom you
really [__] hit it out of the park
that was great you are a [__] star
i appreciate you with all my [__]
heart you know i would watch you and go
wow
she's bringing something different to
the table and now i know what it is
you're bringing to the table you got a
lot of heart man
you got a lot of [__] heart harlem
filled your heart with [__] balls and
toughness
you're the real deal dardooch
homage to kathy moriarty
i love her too i haven't seen her in
years she still have the pizza place
you know i don't know i'm not clear i
spoke to her about uh
maybe three weeks ago
i i didn't
i forgot what she said i think i asked
her but i forgot what she said
i forgot yeah they opened up a new one
by my house before i moved
from la they had opened up a new pizza
place by my house
i had gone to it once it was good you
know it was
their pizza good pizza pizza yeah
yeah they opened one in studio city
before i left so
it was great
um
how long is your podcast are we going
too long no that's it we're done oh okay
okay we're not filming anymore
no we're filming we're gonna end right
now
i love you to death i'm happy you came
on today it was tremendous they're gonna
[__] love you
let these savages know where they could
find you
do you have any social media anything
yes i just started following you coco
and that's my niece's name shout out to
coco they could find me i don't know i
guess on on uh instagram twitter
not gucci
that's it really i don't have anything
fancy i have instagram no website
no okay
i love you not douche you should start
one of these podcasts narducci you're
very good at this
no i like
i i i know you [__] just blew me away
today so
you're very good at this i don't get
blown away too much
you have some deep knowledge so i love
you to death
you have a new fan a bigger fan i was a
fan already now i'm a bigger [__] fan
because i got to look at your heart and
what you're about so thank you very much
for coming on today
and let's stay in touch okay
i'm going to call you every week and be
in touch with you and these guys know
i keep in touch with people i don't [__]
around when i love you i love you to
death so
i appreciate you taking the time to come
on today
[Music]
from
so
[Music]
hmm
you